what's up everyone I'm currently in
South San Francisco I am at this
insanely interesting expansion of
biotechnology infrastructure that is
going up in South San Francisco and just
to give you an idea South San Francisco
is between San Francisco and San Jose it
is on Interstate 101 and it's right
before the airport the San Francisco
International Airport so this is still
quite close to San Francisco at South
San Francisco but it's still not all not
down to the airport and not in this
latter half of the peninsula like Google
and Stanford and stuff like that so all
right so this is the building that you'd
probably see a lot of when you when
you're going on 101 right here it's a
successfactors right there at the top so
that's the building that you're likely
an s AP company you're likely driving by
that building so next time you drive by
the building take the exit for Oyster
Point and go out to this boy stur Point
area and explore here let me tell you
why this is absolutely nuts okay first
of all you guys probably know that I'm a
mentor at Indy bio the largest biotech
accelerator in the world
biology is an insanely important
technology for us to all understand and
not only the way that it's going to
augment our world and make it a better
place doing things like growing meat
instead of slaughtering animals doing
things like storing digital data inside
of DNA doing other incredible parsing
and understanding the code of life a TCG
all of our genomics proteomics omics
sequencing understanding our body I can
go on for too long but biotech is super
important and there's a massive
explosion going on in terms of the
amount of biotech companies that are
blossoming and now taking over massive
industrial space like this so alright so
take a look at this this is something
that I first want you to look at this is
kind of the entry into one of there now
you can see it quite well I just changed
the light focus so that's the entry
point into one of these sort of new
facilities and I just want to show you
there's like this
really interesting guests checking
machine right there I can get lost in
all of this but okay so let's refocus on
me perfect okay so that's just the entry
points to security guard they're the
three companies you should know the
three companies AstraZeneca med immune
assertive pharma and pearl so four okay
so that's first that's just one building
out of all of these buildings by the way
Jessica's with me what's up Jessica and
so we're just you're just jamming super
hard on all this so we actually came out
here and we're playing around with the
bocce ball they have which is nuts this
is very interesting how they're starting
to compete these technology parks are
starting to compete with the googles and
the Facebook's with all their amenities
check out this communal amenity a little
basketball court what else we got a nice
little volleyball net right here for or
I guess back in and VII or best in
badminton that's what I meant badminton
net there's all this stuff for you to
play with here there's this awesome
other five story five story five stories
building right there here's the bocce
ball right here we're messing around
with it earlier playing with physics and
[ __ ] alright now there's these two
ping-pong tables right here I'm taking
you to a really cool thing stay with me
for a moment I'm gonna take you to a
couple cool things we're already 3:30 in
I want to make sure to end this video by
seven there's a lot to talk about
alright so so check this out I'm
currently in an amphitheater you can
even hear it
hello you can hear the way that this
little area is starting to reflect sound
waves off of these back walls and then
it's a little half sphere so anyway
they're adding all these interesting
amenities I got to show you the
construction on the way to the
construction I'm going to show you the
little putting green they have are here
it's a potting Green if a putting green
this is what is going on
look at how they're all competing for
the best amenities and I have to end on
uber or transit to these areas I'm gonna
blow your mind with that as well all
right I'm currently heading over to an
area that's going under construction and
I want you to see this area it's very
important that you see this area when
you when you see this you'll understand
why this is nuts because most people
don't they don't go and look at
construction and think about oh look at
the architecture and the design and look
at the plumbing in the electrical and
the mechanical engineering and all the
things that have to go into this these
massive cranes that are next to the
structures what do they do right we
don't think about these things we don't
think about taking a snapshot of this
incredible construction going on all the
time and I was thinking earlier that I
should rent a [ __ ] car and drive
around the Bay Area so I can better
understand when companies are taking
over massive industrial parks how
important is that just go rent a car
every couple of months in the Bay Area
and go drive around so you can figure
out what companies are moving where in
the Bay Area what massive industrial
parks are making the seps of nuts
all right check this out so here we are
at the cove so that's called the cove at
Easter Point foundry and Lux right there
okay so that's where we're at the
company the company across the street is
a biopharma can't get you the name
there've on I think
Thermo Fisher Scientific is here across
the street right there thermal Fisher
you can't really see it there thermal
Fisher's right there behind my hand and
then look at this building that's under
construction you got to understand how
important it is to realize the craziness
of what's going on right there and how
they're building these different
structures across the bay to house all
these corporate companies that are
receiving venture funding that are
creating biotechnology ideas into the
world and that this whole ecosystem is
exploding and that all the people that
effort has to go into constructing that
building that this is all a massive
biotech explosion and we just have to
better parse and understand how venture
money flows into these businesses all
these businesses have that massive
contractors predict that investors
predict that this is gonna happen build
those buildings they've companies fill
them and that is just a nut cycle in
that sense okay now I want you to think
about this okay there's also five prime
by the way I ran past five prime really
quickly that's that's that is that is
another biotech company there's a bunch
of them okay quick alright quick since
I'm in the light I'm going to end this
by explaining the phenomenon of the
transit that's occurring to this area so
so realize that out of the companies
that are here a lot of people live in
San Francisco or they live in other
nearby areas and not everyone has a car
and so because not everyone has a car a
lot of people are going to be taking
uber here and this is confirmed through
some of my friends that are already
doing this process but they are sending
their employees this area via uber every
day from San Francisco this area the
ones that
and in city compounding warehouse so
means two trips per day from work to
home to work from work to home from home
to work around 8:00 or 9:00 10:00 a.m.
back around 4:00 or 5:00 6:00 p.m. so
anyway there's gonna be a massive
concentration of ride-sharing that needs
to occur at these massive industrial
hubs that are popping up along the
peninsula again for those that don't
know this is South San Francisco but
between San Jose and San Francisco we
have Google we have Stanford we have
Facebook Linkedin Apple we have all
these massive headquartered companies
NASA Ames singularity University there's
endless it's amazing how much is built
in this area so anyway it is nuts to
think about the amount of public transit
shared transit system that's gonna be
coming here think about that as well so
as you think about these buildings going
up as think about these areas being
industrially expanded to think about
also all the ripple effects into the
economy such as even down to
ride-sharing every single day how is
that gonna impact the economy start in
people's lives and these companies being
built and what impact they're gonna have
on other people in the world so you have
all these indicators about the future
that are literally coming at my face
your face all of us and think about how
few people see these things you have to
be here seeing this ahead of other
people that gives you foresight that
gives you a better understanding you can
come and disseminate what you learn to
other people through con through content
like this to video like this and it's as
simple as literally holding your phone
and talking to yourself just like this
and then sharing it with other people so
go do it you know what I say don't just
consume this content go create I hope
that you learn something and that you'll
go write or make videos about it
yourself or start companies in the space
and much love everyone thanks for tuning
in this has been a very fun time out
here in South San Francisco and I'm
rockin
scarf action right now and thanks to my
girl Jessica yeah yeah I I have to say I
get some swag points for sure with the
scarf I'm learning scarfs much love
everyone thanks for tuning in peace